the storyline of the movie is set at the
end of the 19th century in a wealthy
french family lives a beautiful woman
named eugenie her closest companion is
her brother he is also the only person
who knows about a special ability
eugenie possesses she has the power to
talk to the dead feel their pain and
communicate their thoughts with the
living when she interacts with them she
breathes heavily trembles and does
things involuntarily sounds like 99 of
the people who watch amaranth streams
until now she has only had a few such
experiences but as eugenie grows up she
is becoming more and more prone to manic
episodes one night she is tucking her
grandmother into sleep when the woman
asks her if she went to a friend's
funeral unlike how a normal person would
reply eugenie claims that she had a lot
of fun because there were many people
the grandmother is used to eugenie's
bizarre behavior which she thinks is
worrying but doesn't say much about it
on her way back to her room eugenie
hears whispers coming from the hallways
upon checking she finds her brother
making out with a man she smiles and
rushes back to her room the following
day she sneaks into his carriage asking
him to drop her off at the market he
discovers that she knows about his gay
relationship but trusts her enough to
know she won't tell their father
eugenie is not allowed to go outside
alone but her brother cannot protest now
that she knows his secret a while later
she is let off at the market where she
enjoys some alone time walking down the
street then she enters a cafe and sits
across from a man reading a book about
spirits the two exchange glances until
the guy introduces himself to her he
immediately starts flirting and even
though eugenie is uncomfortable at first
she eventually feels at ease because of
his jokes she admits that she wasn't
looking at him but at the book that he
is reading before eugenie leaves the man
lends her the book and asks her to
return it when she is done reading at
night eugenie starts reading the book
and is instantly intrigued by it it has
chapters about the spirit world the
purpose of their existence and even
about human spirit interactions this
gives eugenie a lot of information about
herself and what she can do to help the
spirits who want her assistance while
she is at it her brother cuddles with
her and the two talk about their love
lives that's that's weird in the
following scene the siblings and their
family go on an outing with another
wealthy family the daughter of another
family is single so the adults want her
to take an interest in eugenie's brother
although he is not interested in her he
pretends to like her in order to not
seem suspicious eugenie sees her brother
struggling and interrupts the two this
causes the girl to leave them alone but
earns her disapproval from their father
he has always been less interested in
eugenie because she doesn't fit the
description of the rich snobby girl
whose only hobby is extravagance she is
kind and sympathetic to the weak which
her father thinks is equality of the
poor one night eugenie is helping her
grandmother brush her hair as her
nightly routine suddenly she stops
mid-sentence and goes through an intense
manic episode she involuntarily pulls
out a drawer and starts making a mess of
the things inside before finding a
necklace when everything stops the
grandmother is in shock the necklace was
a gift from her late husband which has
been missing for the past 40 years they
thought someone stole it and stopped
looking for it decades ago the woman
always knew eugenie was special but on
seeing what she can do she doesn't know
if it is a good thing she asks her how
she knew where the necklace was and
eugenie replies that her grandfather
told her the following morning she is
woken up by her mother who says that the
father is taking her to the store today
eugenie is excited and unable to notice
the sadness in her mother's voice she
naively gets dressed and joins her
father and brother in a carriage even
after noticing the vast change in her
brother's behavior she doesn't suspect
anything strange it is only when her
eyes land on the luggage under the seat
that she realizes they are not just
going to the market she looks out the
window and sees a woman staring into
nothingness two orderlies come to pick
her up and forcefully drag her into the
building she begs her father and brother
to help her but both of them remain
seated when she is far enough her
brother starts vomiting out of fear and
guilt inside she is stripped naked and
checked for any physical injuries or
abnormalities throughout all of this she
protests that she is not insane but now
only the doctors can decide that her
freedom is snatched away and her sole
purpose becomes to prove that she is not
insane while every minute detail of her
character is studied she also has to
share a room with many other women some
of whom are actually mentally ill while
the others have been falsely imprisoned
by powerful men who wanted to get rid of
them the sanest one out of all of them
is a woman named louise she befriends
eugenie and helps her settle in although
better than the rest of the women louise
has quite an eccentric behavior herself
the following morning louise is taken to
be examined by the male doctors of the
asylum they hypnotize her and treat her
like a subject to their experiments
rather than a patient they are not in
the least sympathetic when she falls
down and starts trembling because of
their malpractices the only staff who
care about the patients is the head
nurse genevieve she is a kind woman who
is aware of the doctor's cruel ways of
treating patients but cannot raise her
voice against her employers a while
later a young doctor named jules comes
to louise and pretends like he is
worried for her in reality he is a
pervert who lusts for his patience and
takes advantage of their situations he
has promised louise that he will marry
her someday hence she lets him pleasure
himself in front of her as days pass
eugenie starts getting more intense
episodes she hides them well and doesn't
let anyone know about her power scared
of being experimented on but one
afternoon she tells nurse genevieve in a
moment of weakness she reveals that she
talked to genevieve's late sister and
proves it by saying things that only
genevieve would know the nurse is
shocked but she still doesn't want to
believe her the following day is the day
of her final evaluation the doctor asks
her several questions and makes her
admit that she has been seeing spirits
again when he says that she has to be
kept in the asylum for longer eugenie
loses patience and starts yelling at him
she makes a huge mistake by doing so
because the doctor declares that she has
hysteria in the asylum anyone with
hysteria has to go through hydrotherapy
it is a process where patients are laid
in a box full of ice for hours until
their body goes numb and they do not
feel pain anymore many women have died
because of this practice but the doctors
believe it is the best way to make women
less loud eugenie protests and refuses
to oblige but the orderlies throw her
into the box and restrain her inside she
shivers and begs for several minutes
before giving up and accepting her fate
as it is in the evening genevieve is on
her way back home when she feels
someone's presence behind her it turns
out to be eugenie's brother who is
worried about her and wants to know how
she is doing genevieve decides to stay
true to her position as a nurse and
maintains her patients confidentiality
before leaving he hands her the book
about spirits that eugenie was reading
prior to being sent to the asylum
genevieve is supposed to give the book
to eugenie however she cannot help but
read it herself first she completes the
entire thing in one night and is
disturbed by its content although
genevieve is a true believer in science
the book makes her register that eugenie
could be telling the truth meanwhile in
the asylum eugenie is finally let free
she cuddles with louise to remain warm
for the rest of the night but she hardly
gets any sleep the next day she is
approached by genevieve who wants to
communicate with her late sister she
offers eugenie the book and a chance to
meet her brother if she agrees to help
her eugenie says a meeting with her
brother is not enough she wants complete
freedom from this place it is next to
impossible but genevieve promises to do
what she can in the following scene the
two are alone together in a room eugenie
is trying to form a connection with
genevieve's sister but is unsuccessful
as genevieve starts questioning her
powers something takes over eugenie she
starts trembling and says that something
bad has happened to genevieve's father
not wanting to take the risk the nurse
runs to her home and finds a bloodied
napkin on the dining table fortunately
she reaches just in time to rescue her
father who is about to fall unconscious
then another month passes in the asylum
in the same fashion eugenie freezes in
an ice bath every day gets her ovaries
checked frequently and watches the girls
being assaulted by the doctors one
afternoon she notices that the doctors
have made a patient frantic because of a
medicine overdose they show no remorse
for being the cause of her misery and
instead joke about her situation eugenie
is enraged by their nonchalance she
calls them out for using women to
fulfill their sexual desires and their
absurd medical theories when she doesn't
stop cursing at them she is sent into
isolation under a different nurse named
jean she is sadistic and treats the
patients like toys much like the male
doctors eugenie is kept in a tiny room
with only one window that remains closed
most of the day inside the room she
hears the voices of many spirits who
have died there it is terrifying to her
and she begs and cries to be put
somewhere else but gene doesn't care as
days pass eugenie gets more and more
scared jean only gives her a minute of
sunlight and closes the window for most
of the day she eats leftover food and
loses sleep because of all the noises as
a result her health deteriorates rapidly
one afternoon jean enters the room and
mocks her eugenie keeps quiet as the
nurse eats delicious food in front of
her then suddenly she gets a vision of
jean's late mother and finds out she
also died in the same room after gene
falsely admitted her to the asylum the
nurse remains unfazed by the information
and doesn't regret killing her own
mother but then eugenie brings up the
topic of her child's death it is
revealed that jean's mother murdered her
child which is why she killed her jean
breaks down into tears for a few seconds
before strangling eugenie she orders her
to keep her child's name out of her
mouth before walking away leaving
eugenie shaken jean is walking down the
hallway when a girl bumps into her and
steals the keys to the isolation rooms
she hands them to genevieve revealing
that it was her idea to steal them later
she goes to eugenie and talks to her
through the door eugenie has
communicated with genevieve's sister
once again she transfers their messages
to each other and gives them closure
genevieve is so thankful that she
decides to help eugenie later that day
she tells the head doctor that eugenie
has improved exponentially ever since
she was moved into isolation although
suspicious he allows her to join the
common ward again after coming out of
the dark room eugenie meets louise who
is now bound to a wheelchair because of
all the malpractices she was forced to
go through then comes the day of the
annual ball in the asylum it is the one
day in the year when the women get to
dress up dance and enjoy life as though
they were normal eugenie's brother also
gets an invitation and joins the party
the siblings see each other after almost
a year but have to act like they don't
know each other in another room the
doctors flirt with the women and take
advantage of their authority louise is
also approached by jules who uses his
same old promises to make her consent to
whatever he wishes meanwhile eugenie and
her brother make a run for it through
the front gate they are almost caught by
gene but the other women help them by
restraining her the women go wild after
that and start hitting the doctors jules
is strangled to the ground and is
finally taught a lesson by louise
outside genevieve refuses to come with
eugenie wanting to remain with the other
women who need her the scene cuts to a
few months later eugenie lives on the
coast of france far from everything she
has ever known she is happy and
satisfied for the first time in her life
then there is genevieve who has herself
been admitted to the asylum she is at
peace with herself and her situation
especially knowing that her late sister
is in a better place subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching